President Trump is in Ireland president
rebus is true he said he was excited to
sample some traditional Irish cuisine
yeah yeah then he ordered a shamrock
shake he said yeah this is actually what
I would take yeah
but he can write his mouth with his tie
after that from what I understand in
Ireland the shamrock shake has a potato
in it potato in it yeah yeah and it's
not extra yeah exactly sure that Trump
has a golf course in Ireland true story
yeah president Trump's golf course in
Ireland cost him 41 million dollars and
has never turned a profit that's true
yeah in other words it's his most
successful property the he got to the
potato at the bottom and today I love
this is true story the prime minister of
Ireland met President Trump at an
airport lounge yeah yeah only in Ireland
would the Prime Minister be hanging out
at an airport Irish people don't talk
that way I know it's harder to imitate
the real thing no the real thing there
yeah I grew up next to a guy who was
born in Ireland and every morning
that's how they really tried like
there's gravel in their mouth yeah